grace mullane was murdered on the eve of
her 22nd birthday
this is the last time she was seen alive
caught on cctv in a lift in auckland new
zealand
in the company of her killer now his
identity has finally been revealed
along with his history of sexual
violence
jesse kempson pictured here in court was
26 years old when he murdered grace
only eight months before he raped
another british tourist who he met on
the tinder dating app
and he previously terrorized a live-in
girlfriend forcing her into sex acts
he has since been convicted of both
crimes
kempson also met grace on tinder she was
at the beginning of a round-the-world
backpacking trip
they spent several hours at bars and
restaurants in downtown auckland
on the 1st of december 2018. the last
message grace sent to parents was a
picture of a christmas tree
taken that day later they returned to
his serviced apartment
where he strangled her to death kempson
packed grace's body into this suitcase
loaded it into a rental car then buried
her in shallow earth outside the city
he had become obsessed with online
dating in his early twenties
he was a serial liar telling people he
had cancer
that his cousin played for the all
blacks rugby team that he was connected
to gangs
the new zealander today lost his final
appeal against his conviction and life
sentence for grace's murder
and along with it his anonymity after
the ruling from the court of appeal the
mullaine family said
grace was a kind fun-loving daughter
sister
granddaughter niece auntie cousin and
friend with her whole life ahead of her
she was enjoying the first of what would
have been a lifetime of adventures
before her life was so cruelly and
brutally cut short by her murderer
grace's family have set up a charity
called love grace
which donates handbags full of items to
victims of domestic abuse
her life was ended brutally by kempson
but her warmth and her kindness
endure tom cheshire sky news